the Joe Rogan experience like you're
experiencing so many different facets of
life on earth like you're going to all
these different environments and
ecosystems you're in the water and on
the land yeah jungles are on islands
living man I love it and living thanks
very cool I admire it but it comes you
know like your buddy you know who got
the diseases from the Congo it comes
with its costs like you know we are in
Borneo this year and we were at a
research station in the middle of the
jungle and I don't know enough about B
ecology but it was like bee season and I
mean you you should see some of our
videos on Instagram it's like I'm
talking about covered head-to-toe and
bees we were taking like forty to fifty
stings on average per day per person but
you know and it this is so miserable
forty to fifty a day there's eight hours
in a day yeah so you're you're literally
taking stings all day long well no it's
worse than that because we were only at
the station in the morning or evenings
right before waking up or going to bed
the rest of time we're out in the field
not taking stings so you're taking like
twenty five when you wake up and like
twenty five before you go to bed so when
you're doing this is there a way to
prevent it is there it like can you use
like a repellent nothing worked we you
know we like put like scarves over our
heads and you know and these one is not
Hornets right they sting you they die
yes but then when we were on that
getting that came in we we encountered
Hornets that put my cameraman into
anaphylactic shock they were so bad oh
great yeah so we it comes with its cost
which I think my point was it makes you
appreciate the comforts so much more
when you get back see that tarantula
hawk and look I did last file I did I
was picking it up right right before you
walked in my buddy Maynard sent me that
yeah
yeah he's got it from Arizona man yeah
that's from his he owns a vineyard and
he a farm in Arizona and he was telling
me about these things and he got a dead
one said to me they're super cool look
at the size of that [ __ ] it's yard and
they come out of holes in the ground
Hunter Angela's like you know they're
still yeah yeah it's hello everybody
yeah so I mean the tarantula hawk it's a
parasitic
right so it comes out it hunts for
tarantulas it lays its eggs I believe in
the abdomen of the tarantula and then
the eggs hatch and explode out of the
tarantula and that's the life cycle you
beautiful fantastic complicated cruel
[ __ ] it's insane oh my god I'm sure
you've seen the video of those Hornets
that visit this beehive they visit a
honeybee hive and just start these
Japanese Hornets and they just start
chopping off the heads off the bees no
way I can't believe I'm telling you
about ant a tree there's a certain
species of Hornets that flies into honey
bees I think it's Japanese Hornets they
fly into these hives of honeybees and
just decimate the honeybees they cut
their heads off with their their
mandibles or a pump chop-chop and
there's so much bigger so they fly in
and there's a slow-motion video of these
enormous Hornets flying in and
decapitating thousands and thousands of
honeybees so what's interesting is the
honeybees they're so outsized I mean the
Hornets are literally like 50 60 times
larger right you see it there they're
very just so maybe that's not the right
number but they're much much larger and
they're much more powerful but the
honeybees figured out a strategy to kill
the Hornets and what they do is they
surround them they get on top of them
and then they beat their wings they all
generate heat and then they kill the the
Hornets with the heat of their body
that's unbelievable unbelievable yeah so
here's this thing that's decapitating
everyone in your little village right
and so you have to jump on top of it and
flex and heat it up yeah but the fact
that they were able to devise this
strategy see look how they do it man
they just grab ahold of these bees and
just decapitate them it's unbelievable
they're of these horrific faces right
these giant mandibles yeah I can see
that and they're just swarm in and they
just look at it they're just chopping
these [ __ ] honeybees apart you you
said it nature you cruel beautiful [ __ ]
rule beautiful 30
Hornets versus 30,000 bees do you know
why the Hornets are doing this are they
getting honey we want the larva a larva
yeah yeah they probably want the larva
or they want the honey they want
something but look at all these dead
[ __ ] bees with no heads bizarre crazy
it's not I mean it's it's just so weird
right that that you know that nature
devises these sort of strategies to
prevent overpopulation and that there's
this balance that takes place where you
know the bees are threatened by
something that's very be like so you see
how there's getting on top of them yeah
so that's that's their strategy for for
dealing they all get on top of them so
you see a bunch of them now and he's
trying to get away but he can't fly away
and so then they swarm and then they
eventually kill him so you think that
actually like cooks the wasp something
it overheats their body and it fort see
it how many of them are on there yeah
there's something that it does where it
overheats their body Wow the size the
size comparison there's so much bigger
imagine if you had that Hornet you know
that was six feet long
oh my god I think giant insects would be
the worst the worst yeah the worst I
think would be preying mantises the [ __ ]
out of me mm-hmm we've been on a praying
mantis kick lately bit watch them kill
rats and yeah everything hummingbirds
the hummingbird one is the wildest one
they sit by a hummingbird feeder I hit
they're not moving and the hummingbird
comes to feed they just just spirit
snatch them it's crazy it's so strong
yeah sighs yeah you know there was one
with a mouse and the mouse is so much
bigger than the praying mantis praying
mantis just jacks this mouse it's crazy
it's wild it's wild creature man yeah
they're amazing
really cool-looking though I see him all
the time I find them all the time when
I'm running mm-hmm yeah ya know they're
they're amazingly cool and very diverse
you know there's huge ones or small ones
they're spread out all over the world
they're amazing animals what is this one
got a snake makes this is lots of them
it's like a highlight video oh look at
that it's got a [ __ ] snake yeah I
think we can't even imagine how strong
they would be if they were our size now
I think they would run right through
walls oh yeah they would I mean look at
this
[ __ ] he's taking on a giant snake
that's Nate is like two feet long and
he's a little ass humming little ass
pregnant ass and he's [ __ ] it up he's
literally eating it yeah yeah they're
pulling chunks out they're insane and
they have such crazy eyesight and like
they're literally covered in body armor
with their exoskeleton like they're just
they're amazing well they seem like what
you would think of as being like a
horrific animal that lives on another
planet
totally totally like do you remember
that movie Starship Troopers of course I
loved that middle of dit and that was
one of the things in the Starship
Troopers like these big giant insect
gems that were sitting out of the ground
shooting stuff out of their butts and
they're great I love that movie yeah
Cort Cory Rico yeah yeah that was a fun
movie right yeah kind of tongue-in-cheek
totally but also like really gory in
total and yeah Neil Patrick Harris yeah
yeah it's great that's such a fun movie
I mean that's great stuff I said we're
really fortunate for those things are
small that all move all insects are
small we would be on the menu otherwise
no doubt about it like there to like
indiscriminately perfect hunters big big
you know predatory insects is there a
history on the fossil record of enormous
bugs like isopods and things like that
but I can't not that I know of like you
know 6 foot long preying mantises
[Applause]